[Aplausos]
faltou novamente são paulo pimenta vem
cá hoje falar um crime futura fia aquilo
que eu faço
vou mostrar três projetos que têm a ver
com a minha maneira de comunicar a estar
a intervir
todos os dias o uso da fotografia como
um meio mais eficaz está cá é é o
tamanho faz respirar os dias quando a
vontade de voltar e continuar é é a
lutar e e andar pra frente com isso eu
tenho três projetos aqui o primeiro é na
casa foi um projeto que eu desenvolvi
durante um ano
numa das zonas mais pobres do porto
a ideia foi mesmo está com acento se ao
usando a fotografia como como maio
denúncia de intervenção em que
pudéssemos depois através do meu
trabalho e é este não seja o do doce
stencial chama zé antônio pinto mais
conhecido por chamar esse trabalho que
eu fiz foi na zona da oriental em campo
ganhar é um ponto em que depois em
relação ao trabalho pois podemos alterar
alguma coisa é eu eu eu
com isso não quer dizer que quero mudar
o mundo mas se eu puder todo dias mudar
uma vírgula pra mim é o mais importante
eu tenho dificuldades em falar em
público
por isso também é uma das coisas
importantes para mim é através da
fotografia é e do trabalho que eu faço é
minha maneira falar portanto vou cursar
mostrar esse trabalho que é essa imagem
que mann sufoco
tenho e porque isso vai se apresentar em
3d três situações as imagens como foco
as imagens com uma só eram e as imagens
com o colchão pronto este é o meu
primeiro trabalho
[Risadas]
o
[Música]
[Risadas]
o
[Música]
enquanto isto só pará uepa além dos
trabalhos que eu faço em que o autor é
eu sou faltou jornalista do público e
tenho porque vai estar num nicho não dá
prioridade desenvolver muita coisa
estará constantemente a trabalhar e ser
gentil comigo próprio e por estar a
trabalhar após oito anos
além destas situações que vou tendo
diariamente tem outras situações que uma
catalisando é também tenho as imagens é
uma certa forma uma sequela e uma das
áreas que nã o que eu tenho gosto de
fazer o que gosta de procurar é é a área
do do espetáculo pronto o palco a atriz
palco pronto e é e uma das coisas que
faço muito em festivais música que é uma
das coisas que eu gosto e até mesmo a
seleção são frações de segundos é são
momentos que nós temos poucos momentos
em que temos para captar para estar ali
pensamento é brigar até o momento
[Música]
pronto esta é uma das partes que o dólar
fazendo e usa futuro filme era pra
segurar o bastante e outra parte que eu
uso muito a minha futura fia que faz
parte do meu cotidiano e que o que eu
também acredito é o relaxamento e uma de
bronze uma das minhas partes
relacionamento é é facto uma promoção
que eu tenho comigo uma testemunha está
numa instituição passa muito tempo com
ela fora da instituição
ian desafio a um tempo em maio
a nível global a fazer um dia a
fotografia em que a idéia era nós
passarmos um dia a fotografar alguém e
esse alguém eu escolhi a miníma e foi um
dia fantástico todos os dias são
fantásticas com ela e é também uma
maneira de eu estar com ela a fotografar
é comunicar porque não não publica muito
não é
mas a fotografia é usada para comunicar
com ela mas que seja papel a dizer que
não quero mais fotografias ao que já
chegou o lanche porque pronto eu também
gosto do estádio está com ela
é uma maneira de também guardar isso é a
fotografia também é o clube faz o
achamento que o guardar o primeiro achar
com as situações como dizem muito
[Música]
ah
ah ah ah ah ah
pronto está o que cria a partilhar
convosco é isto também é minha maneira
comunicado é travessa da fotografia
comunicado intervir giro e é isso que eu
faço disso é procurar o meu equilíbrio
através da imagem através de trabalho
fazendo o que posso ou não alterar
alguma coisa é mas acima de tudo
continuar sempre a lutar ea fazer a
fazer à minha procura a exaustiva a
gente até o limite passará muito muito
tempo a futura fábrica está usando
fotografia tamanho para eu poder fazer
alguma coisa um próprio e para os outros
pronto isso era isso que eu queria
também partilhar convosco e pronto
[Música]